(electronic whooshing)
(mouse clicking)
(electronic chiming)
(upbeat music)
- I'm John Campbell,
I'm a philosophy professor
here at Berkeley,
and I'd like to welcome you
to this Howison Lecture.
George Holmes Howison was born in 1844.
He began academic life as a mathematician
at the University of
Washington at St. Louis.
But while in St. Louis
he encountered a collection
of rather rumbustious,
larger than life academic characters
who were reading Hegel's
Phenomenology of Spirit.
The St. Louis Hegelians
were a very vibrant force.
They were very engaged
with, opposed to the
emerging naturalism in
American philosophy,
which ultimately swept them away.
Howison's legacy was
perhaps the most enduring
of any of the St. Louis Hegelians.
Josiah Royce was, in
some ways, his nemesis,
and Howison wrote about Royce,
"The most depressing sign
about Royce's thinking
"is that he seems perfectly aware
"how this makes no provision
"either for immortality
"or for real freedom,
"and yet he appears to have
no uneasiness under it,
"but to contemplate this
ghastly destiny of ours
"with a complacency even
savoring of self satisfaction."
"In contrast," Howison wrote,
"the causality of self consciousness,
"the causality that creates
and incessantly recreates
"in the light of its own idea,
"and by the attraction of it as an ideal
"originating in the self
consciousness purely
"is the only complete causality,
"because it is the only form of being
"that is unqualifiedly free."
The kind of gusto
that comes over in these remarks, I think,
Howison became the holder
of the first endowed chair
in philosophy at Berkeley,
and he built the philosophy department.
He was clearly an influential
and much loved individual.
I know in his death,
his friends and colleagues
put together a fund
which is funding today's lecture
to continue his work
by bringing the most influential
and interesting thinkers of the day
out to the rural wilderness of California.
And I think we couldn't
have a better person
to continue with that role today
than Gisela Striker.
She was Walter C. Klein
Professor of Philosophy
and of the Classics at Harvard.
She specializes in ancient philosophy,
teaching Plato and Aristotle,
as well as later Greek and Roman authors.
She's written mostly on topics
in Hellenistic philosophy
and Aristotelian logic.
She's the author
of Essays on Hellenistic
Epistemology and Ethics,
and others are the
translation and commentary
on Aristotle's Prior Analytics Book I.
Her current works are
revision and translation
of the text of the Loeb edition
of Aristotle's Rhetoric.
She was named the Professor
of Classical Philosophy
at Harvard in 1989,
and the George Martin Lane
Professor of Philosophy
and of the Classics in 1990.
She left her world in 1997
to become the Laurence
Professor of Ancient Philosophy
at the University of Cambridge.
Three years later, she
returned to her world
to be greeted by the headline,
A Peripatetic Returns.
And she stayed there
until her retirement in 2011.
She said that working
through a text slowly
and talking about it as you go,
without the pressure of providing
a bibliography or a paper,
is a way of generating new ideas.
Our title today is Cicero's De Officiis,
Stoic Ethics Without Metaphysics.
Please join me in
welcoming Gisela Striker.
(audience applauding)
- I like the story about Howison,
but I'm not a Hegelian at all,
so it won't be inspiring.
Can't help that.
On the other hand, you know,
not everybody can be as inspiring
as the Washington Hegelians,
so you'll have to put up with whatever.
I hope everybody has a handout,
and we'll see whether, you know,
you don't get too bored
with good old Cicero,
you know, whose prestige
has considerably lessened
since the time that everybody
had to read his book.
So anyway,
let me say a few words
about the title of this talk
and then also about Cicero.
I left the title in Latin,
which wasn't just pure arrogance.
It was simply because that was the title
during the time that this
particular book by Cicero
was the most influential,
namely, between the Renaissance,
and well, the early 19th century.
That was a time when
everybody had to read Cicero.
Cicero was, at the time,
for the people who were reading him,
a philosopher rather than what we now
tend to think of him,
as an orator or maybe a politician.
He was, as it were,
on the curricula of anybody who studied
something like philosophy in college,
but his influence even went wider.
It was such that, I think,
every sort of educated gentleman
in most European countries,
certainly in England,
was expected to have read that book.
And so Hume, for example,
which I always liked,
refers to it comfortably
as Tullius Officiis.
He doesn't have to explain, you know?
Everybody knows what's meant.
So Tullius Officiis is,
I mean, it was Marcus Tullius Cicero,
so that was Cicero's family name.
Tullius Officiis was, as it were,
a part of every aspiring
young gentleman's education
up to the turn of the 18th century.
So that's the book I wanted to talk about,
but then there is also another thing,
Cicero's prestige, of course, went down,
that's why I said up to the beginning
of the 19th century,
when people became obsessed with the idea
of originality and genius.
And also, when the history of philosophy
became a little bit more,
as it were, historically informed,
and people were not just treated
as though they had sort of inscribed
and toned their doctrines,
and you could treat them as though
they were all from the same time.
So that was actually Hegel's fault.
So he does come up. (chuckles)
So then at that time, you know,
people began talking about Cicero
was not at all an original philosopher,
nor, I have to say,
would he ever have
claimed to have been one.
And also, I think, at least
some ancient historians
decided that he was no
good as a politician.
So Cicero disappeared,
except for those people
who took the classical
languages in high school,
he disappeared from the
philosophy curriculum.
And also, I think,
that may something to do with
the politics of the time,
but in any case, the book, De Officiis,
which is a kind of book of manners
for aspiring gentlemen,
namely aristocrats,
sort of also
was perhaps less apt to be read
by people living at that time.
Be that as it may,
since Cicero was not an
original philosopher,
and as I said, you know,
the idea that you have to
be an original philosopher
is questionable.
Mmm, yes, most of us aren't,
and you know, philosophy wouldn't exist
if people had to be (chuckles)
original philosophers.
So Cicero
was actually something very important
in the development of European philosophy.
Namely, he was, I think one can say
without much exaggeration,
he was the person who
actually made philosophy,
which was a Greek affair,
as the word still indicates,
familiar to the Romans
by writing books in
Latin about philosophy.
He had studied philosophy,
I think he had had a
very serious interest.
He was well informed about
the philosophies of his days,
and he was a great admirer of Plato,
no doubt because Plato was
not only a philosophical,
but also a literary genius.
And Cicero himself
was evidently a very talented writer,
not just a speaker,
and so he took it upon himself, I think,
to write things in Latin,
so that people, as he
quite correctly says,
can also discuss the subject
in their own language.
It is clear from some remarks
in some of the prefaces
to his philosophical books
that some people said, "No, come on.
"You know, we're all bilingual.
"Everybody knows Greek.
"Why should you do this in Latin?"
But he insisted, and I
think he's quite right,
that in order to appreciate philosophy,
you have to be able to discuss it
with your friends in your own language.
And so I think we owe
a great debt to Cicero,
and then perhaps, as a second,
in the role of Seneca,
who was an admirer
who appeared about 100
years later than Cicero,
that philosophy became something
you could easily do in Latin.
This was not very easy because philosophy,
by the time that Cicero
was beginning that work,
already had developed
quite a bit of terminology
that simply wasn't available.
And we know from Cicero's correspondence
with his friend Atticus
that he often sort of struggled
with finding the right word.
Fortunately, he really
knew Greek extremely well.
He had a fine ear for style and so on.
But he had, for example,
a dispute with Atticus
about whether officii
was the right word to
translate the Greek kathekonta.
However that may be, he did that.
So Cicero was, as it were,
someone who prepared the way
for philosophy being done,
and also, in doing so,
he wanted to introduce some of his
perhaps not quite so bilingual
and educated countrymen
to philosophy itself.
So towards the end of his life,
when he could no longer
act as a politician
because Caesar had sort of won the day,
he decided that he could
serve his country best
by writing a kind of survey
of the main topics of philosophy,
a kind of philosophical encyclopedia,
which is what he did until his death.
Now the De Officiis is
actually his very last book.
It's not part of that encyclopedia.
It was dedicated to his son,
who was spending time in Athens
to get an education, or so Cicero hoped.
But perhaps understandable
with such an overbearing father,
it seems that young Marcus
wasn't so interested in philosophy.
Be that as it may,
Cicero wanted to write this,
and I think it's important to know
because that has sort of made it a book
that sort of is
dedicated to and written for
what Americans tend to
call future leaders.
So young Marcus was not a future leader.
He liked horses and wine better.
But anyway, Cicero chose a topic
that would be accessible to everyone,
you know, not metaphysics or anything
as abstract as even epistemology.
So he chose a book about,
well, how one should act
and how one should deliberate
about you know, what
the right thing to do is
and how one should behave and so on.
He wrote this in the
last month of his life
in a great hurry.
And so in this particular case,
unlike other cases,
it is pretty clear that
he was more or less
following one particular author
and one particular book.
In the other cases,
he usually has read several books,
and people, you know,
spend a lot of time trying
figure out which ones.
Fortunately, in this case,
I don't have to do this.
He was reading Panaetius' book,
the Peri tou Kathekontos,
on appropriate action.
And Panaetius was actually a Stoic.
He was sort of the leader
of the Stoic school
in the second century,
so Cicero didn't know him personally,
but he chose that book,
and that's, of course, important.
At least one reason for
choosing that particular book
was that Panaetius, unlike other Stoics
who were notorious for
their horrible style,
like Chrysippus, he was
always held up as an example
of how one shouldn't write,
Panaetius wrote in elegant literary Greek.
And so Cicero, in other places,
praises him for that.
And that also means that Panaetius
left out some of the hairsplitting
or sometimes even barbaric terminology
that the Stoics tended to indulge in.
They like to make very fine distinctions,
not all of which they
could find in the language,
and so if they couldn't,
they would form their own expressions,
and that made someone like Galen,
a long time afterwards,
say that they probably didn't
even know proper Greek.
Anyway, so they would distinguish between
selecting and choosing.
And you know, you select
one kind of change.
Well, choosing is more important.
But perhaps their most
famous and most awkward term
was preferred indifferent,
or dispreferred indifferent.
That's even nicer.
And one can imagine
that the Romans,
I mean, for whom Cicero was writing,
including, but not only his son,
and who weren't specializing in philosophy
would just have fallen asleep
after about an hour of this kind of stuff.
So Cicero was happy to find a book
that they could read.
And I believe,
I mean, you know,
from what we know about Panaetius,
that it's quite likely
that Panaetius himself
was writing for educated
upper-class Romans,
because at the time, in Panaetius' time,
you know, he was from
the island of Rhodes,
and that was already
part of the Roman Empire.
He came to Rome often.
He was friends with very
prominent Roman politicians.
So I think one can assume
that he probably wrote
for the kind of audience
that would have appreciated
something like that
written in elegant Greek,
but would not have bothered to read books
by the Stoics themselves.
So this is one reason
why I think Cicero chose this book.
Now, people have spent a lot of time
trying to find out what is Cicero
and what is Panaetius.
As it were, Cicero never just translated,
nor did he just paraphrase.
He says, you know, "I
always use my own judgment."
I'm pretty convinced that
he abbreviated quite a lot
in this case, because
he put Panaetius' books
in the shorter version.
And so people have been figuring out
is this Panaetius or not.
That's not what I want to do here.
That's why I started with, you know,
the book as it was written
in the 18th century.
I want to talk about this book.
And I assume that yes, I mean,
in a way, Cicero is the hero of this book
because of his influence,
but Panaetius is
presumably the philosopher
that I'm going to talk about.
But since Panaetius'
own works are all lost,
I thought that giving the
title Panaetius to that talk
would make it, sort of would guarantee
that nobody would show up.
(audience chuckling)
So there we go.
So okay, then one thing to keep in mind,
and I think I, myself,
and perhaps only I, I don't know,
have forgotten it,
Panaetius is not writing a survey
or a general exposition of Stoic ethics.
His title indicates that it's only a part
of Stoic ethic studies
dealing with the part
that is most relevant
for people like Cicero's son,
namely how to behave correctly,
what to do, how to make
decisions and so on.
That is to say he was writing
about appropriate action.
He was not giving, as it were,
a theoretical framework
that the Stoics would have used
to explain why acting in this way
was the correct way of acting.
He could leave it out
in a book like that,
just indicate something.
And so one needs to keep in mind
that this is not all
there is to Greek ethics,
but as I will sort of
be saying at the end,
not if you're living in the 18th century.
So this is about appropriate action,
how we should act,
and unfortunately for us, I think,
Cicero has not preserved
Panaetius' introduction preface.
Well, you know, prefaces
tended to include a dedication,
so Cicero has a dedicatory
epistle to his son,
and then he explains to
him how important it is
that anyone should
really have thought about
how to act and speak correctly and so on.
So it's a very important subject
that anyone who is educated
and not just philosophers
need to know about,
and so on and so forth.
And then,
then he suddenly sadly
falls into something
like rather pedantic
criticisms of Panaetius
without even having mentioned his name
as the author he's following.
I'm following many Stoic ideas.
The fact is, and I haven't
found this mentioned
in any commentary,
which I think is really amusing,
Panaetius doesn't get mentioned
at the beginning, you know,
but he says, "And this
is what he does wrong.
"He doesn't really use the right..."
Okay, so it seems to me
that this is one sign of Cicero
not having had the time
to revise this book.
He didn't.
I mean, when he came back from
the trip on which he wrote it,
he had a few political speeches,
his famous Philippics to give in Rome,
and then he was murdered shortly after.
It was after all the time, his reward.
So I don't think that he would have left
those rather ill-tempered remarks in it
that if he had revised the book.
He would at least have
mentioned Panaetius,
and perhaps complimented
him on his good style,
as he does in some of his other works.
So all we can learn from this introduction
is that the book is intended
as a true deliberation
about you know, decision-making,
and organized around three questions
that will come up.
There's first, the question
whether a proposed action
is honorable or not,
honesto, this is a Latin word.
Then, whether it is useful or expedient.
And sometimes, one would face difficulties
when those two criteria,
the honorable and the useful,
came into conflict with one another.
One footnote, I have kept honorable,
which is closer to the Latin honestum.
It could also be translated,
but I'm not sure that that's
the best way to proceed,
as morally good.
So the question is, you know,
first, you consider
whether this is honorable
in the sense of morally
acceptable or praiseworthy.
Then you consider whether
it's sort of good for you,
useful in that particular sense.
And then, you know, sometimes,
you'll find that those
two things conflict,
and you have to figure out
what to do in such a situation.
Yeah, but that can't have been all
that Panaetius did.
And so instead
of the missing introduction,
I have, on the handout,
I have quoted a line not from Cicero
and from a Greek author,
who unfortunately just,
you know, gives it in a
list of people's definitions
of the aim of life,
and that's Clement Alexandria,
who's a Church Father.
Panaetius declared that the aim of life
is living according to the resources
or starting points given to us by nature.
I don't want to quibble about, you know,
whether that was sort of
the official definition.
We cannot tell from Clement's testimony.
But it does tell us,
and that's why I'm quoting it,
it does tell us what actually
Cicero does at the beginning,
when he evidently turns
to Panaetius' exposition.
So what does it mean
to live according the
resources or starting points?
Aphorme is actually not the same as horme.
Horme is impulses, you
know, historic term.
Aphorme is Panaetius' term.
Well, that's what we get in
the first chapters of that book,
and that's what I'm
going to talk about now.
It begins deceptively,
almost like general
introductions to Stoicism,
mentioning two natural
tendency or impulses that,
according to the Stoics,
all animals, including
humans have in common.
Namely, they all have instinct
for self-preservation,
which, for example, you know,
makes them find the
right kind of nourishment
and so on and so forth,
and they also have an instinct
to care about people of the same species,
and the example tends to be parents
caring for their children.
And that's true not just
of humans, as I said.
This is the famous doctrine of oikeiosis
as being a word that everybody
says is untranslatable.
So it's sort of feel concern for something
as belonging to one.
But then, although he
mentions those two things,
he turns to something
that we do not find in
other Stoic sources,
namely, he, as it were,
applies this to the case of humans.
Each species follows its own nature,
and that means he now
develops the resources
that humans have insofar as
they are rational beings.
So it's not really the
old doctrine of oikeiosis,
of concern, self-concern,
and social concern,
which we find as the basest base
of Stoic ethics in other authors.
Panaetius does seem to
have added something to it,
and he develops a description
of four of these tendencies
based on human rationality,
that together will lead you,
as it were, to virtue,
i.e. he describes them in such a way
that following these tendencies
and reaching the aims that they have
will make you a virtuous person.
This is now,
I'm coming to the next
thing on the handout,
but I'll just summarize because, I mean,
it's going to get too long if I don't.
So he starts out with justice,
and having read Aristotle, no doubt,
he says, "Well, humans have language."
And actually, what we now all see
as the old definition, rational animal,
is much likely to have started
as language-using animal, that's logikon.
Cicero knows that.
He translates it as ratio et oratio,
reason and language.
The word mean both in Greek.
So humans are language users,
and because they're language users,
they are capable of talking,
making plans for the future
and making rules for themselves and so on.
So they are, as Aristotle says,
much more sociable than herd animals
because they can discuss
and set rules for themselves,
they can introduce justice.
So that's the basis of justice.
The next item is knowledge.
Humans are rational,
so they are, by nature,
inclined to try and learn
as much as they can.
They want knowledge.
And then come to other things
that are slightly more problematic.
The next is,
one would expect in this case, courage.
I mean, if it's the four cardinal virtue,
but Panaetius has
magnanimity, magnitudo animi,
which he describes as a
certain desire for leadership.
So as a result of which he says,
"A mind well-equipped by nature
"is not willing to obey anyone,
"except a person who
offers advice or teaching,
"or whose commands given
justly and legitimately
"for the sake of some benefit."
In a later chapter,
when he deals with that
virtue in particular,
he actually calls it a desire for freedom.
So he seems to think
that people have a natural desire
for something like autonomy,
and that's what he's describing here,
and putting in the place of
the usual case of courage.
This is not really deviating
much from the Stoics,
because they had varying lists.
They had lists of everything.
They also had lists of
virtues and sub-virtues,
and usually, it would be courage
and then magnanimity,
but you would also reverse it.
And next comes what is the
second point on the handout,
namely, what must have been, I think,
Panaetius' most important innovation.
We are told that man alone,
as a rational animal,
has a sense of order and propriety
and of the right measure
in words and deeds,
and no other animals then
perceives the beauty,
the loveliness and harmonious
arrangement of parts
in things perceived by sight.
So man's rational nature leads him
to transfer those qualities
from the eyes to the mind,
a transfer, I think, that
would be much easier in Greek,
because the word for inner beauty
or for moral virtue
and for outer formal beauty
is the same, namely, kalon.
So you transfer it from sight,
from the eyes to the mind.
And thinks that beauty,
constancy, and order
should be preserved, and much more so
in one's decisions and in one's deeds.
So first, you say,
as there is the beauty of the body,
so there is the body of the mind,
but then you also say at the bud,
that beauty of the mind
is the more important.
So these people then,
once they have made that transition,
are careful also to do nothing
in an unfitting or
effeminate way as a woman,
in all their opinions and actions,
thinking and doing nothing licentious.
Now this is a change because the Greek,
for some of virtues,
usually has the virtue of
temperance or moderation,
Greek sophrosyne, in this place.
And Cicero actually,
when he sort of resumes,
and in a few paragraphs further down,
what he has said here
includes moderation and temperance.
So in place of that, we find
a tendency to recognize beauty
and then to wish to be beautiful yourself,
not just in the outer sense
on which one can't do much,
but at least in the inner sense,
and that is described
as a harmonious fitting together of parts,
and of course, that corresponds
to the ancient idea of beauty.
They weren't for the romantic
sort of singularities,
they were for symmetry and order
and so on and so forth.
So this is a description of beauty,
and you try to have a
soul that is harmonious
and orderly and so on and so forth.
What that means, I'm not
going to try to explain,
but what's remarkable,
I mean, we (mumbles),
what's remarkable, I think,
about this substitution for sophrosyne
is that it actually is a matter
of recognizing virtue in general.
That's, for example, how Seneca uses it.
He uses the same comparison, no doubt,
he knew Panaetius and he
certainly knew Cicero,
to explain how we arrive at
our first notion of the good,
whereby the good, he evidently means
what the Stoics saw as
highest good, namely virtue.
So he has the same analogy.
You know, you transfer your idea of beauty
from the sight to the mind,
and you then desire to become a person
who has a beautiful mind,
and that shows in a
kind of harmonious soul
and corresponding harmonious behavior.
But it's very odd to
find as a single virtue
something that seems to be a
desire for virtue in general.
Cicero doesn't comment on this.
We cannot tell, of course,
whether it was just like that
in Panaetius' book.
But one thing that I
think one should realize
is that there is, as it were,
a coupling of, I'll call it a faculty,
which is apparently unique to humans.
We might even agree with that,
although, of course, who knows?
Maybe, you know, birds can.
But they usually don't
paint pictures and stuff.
So it's a unique human faculty
of appreciating beauty,
and that's a cognitive faculty.
You can recognize beauty
and you can apparently
recognize inner beauty
from the way that people behave
if they behave in a way
that corresponds to beauty on the outside,
namely, orderly and so on.
Perhaps one can call this
something like integrity.
This is a word that Seneca uses.
But you know, that's not the same
as the somewhat limited virtue
of temperance or moderation.
Now one trivial explanation
of these two substitutions,
which I just mentioned
but don't think could have been decisive,
is that both courage and moderation
aren't usually negatively defined.
Courage, so we'll say,
is to do the right thing without fear.
So courage is mainly the opposite of fear.
Moderation, of course, is
the avoidance of excess.
Now if you are Panaetius
and you want to sort of
talk about tendencies
to reach certain aims
that are proper to rational animals,
then that's not a good idea.
Whereas in the case of magnitudo animi,
of, you know, magnanimity,
he can put leadership
or freedom, autonomy,
as a goal.
And in the case sophrosyne,
he can put beauty as a goal.
That is one possibility.
Well, I think if it were just that,
that would be boring.
The fact is that Cicero,
in this particular passage,
does not explain.
He doesn't even tell us that this is,
he doesn't sort of notify us
that there's two things.
But if we then turn,
and that's the next thing on the handout,
to the end of book one of the De Officiis,
93 to 95,
we get an explanation
and an official recognition
of this double role of the sense of beauty
in Panaetius' theory.
Cicero explains first, you know,
we have to, we get to
the last of the virtues,
and this is
to be explained for as the fitting.
I'm sorry that I couldn't
find a better term.
Again, this is sort of
one that has at least become useful.
The translation that I've
mostly used has seemly,
and that's seems to me to be unseemly,
so I prefer fitting.
So anyway, Cicero sets out
to explain what he means
by this virtue,
saying, "Next, we must
discuss the one remaining part
"of honorableness, of moral virtue,
"and it does appear a sense of shame
"and what one might
call the ordered beauty
"of life, restraint, and modesty."
This sounds more like
sophrosyne than anything else.
"A calming of all the
agitations of the mind
"and the due measure in all things."
And at this setting is included
what in Latin may be called decorum.
The beauty of this is that
decorum is still a word
and I'm absolutely convinced
that the English language
got it from this book.
So decorum,
the Greek word is prepon.
Yeah, the essence of this
is that it cannot be separated
from what is honorable or virtuous,
for what is fitting is honorable
and what is honorable is fitting.
It is easier to understand than to explain
what the difference is
between the honorable and the fitting.
So he goes on a little bit
and then says, "Just as the loveliness
"and beauty of the body
"cannot be separated from health."
I think the comparison
is really helpful here.
So the fitting of which
we are speaking here
is entirely blended with virtue,
but can be distinguished
by thought and reflection.
So the prepon, the
fitting or whatever you
want to call it, decorum.
Decorum is actually
inseparable from virtue.
It is, as he makes clear, I think,
the outer appearance of inner beauty.
He says, you know,
"It doesn't take subtle
reasoning to discern it,
"but it is in plain view."
So what he is saying
is that by prepon,
the Greeks designate something
like the outer visibility
of inner beauty.
Now it's important to realize
that the word prepon had already,
by the time of Panaetius
and before Cicero,
become a very common term
in Greek aesthetic theory,
if you want to call it that,
namely, literary theory.
But perhaps more important
for this particular passage
is that prepon shows up
in Plato's dialogue, Hippias Major,
as a term used to define beauty.
What fits well together to prepon,
Socrates suggests
to Hippias.
Now Plato is not nice to Hippias,
so Hippias is described
as being extremely obtuse.
And so it's not a surprise
that he is unable to defend
the proposed definition
against the objections
that Socrates immediately
proceeds to raise.
When Socrates asks whether to prepon,
as I said, the fitting or
whatever you want to call it,
or decorum, is what makes
things appear beautiful
or what makes them be so,
Hippias opts for appearing,
which, I think, is probably correct
in as far as Greek usage goes.
But that leads to his defeat
as you know, most
interlocutors of Socrates,
of course, lose the battle.
Socrates proceeds to interpret appearance
as more and possibly deceptive appearance,
and argues that this cannot be
what they're looking for under beauty,
namely, what accounts for
things being beautiful.
That's what beauty must be,
and not appearing to be beautiful.
But Panaetius was not Hippias,
and he knew to avail himself
of a distinction that seems
to be missing in Plato,
or i.e. Hippias, you know,
wasn't smart enough to come up with it.
The distinction between appearance
as a outer manifestation
of something as beauty,
I mean physical beauty,
is supposed to be the
manifestation of health,
I mean, that's assuming that true,
and appearance as mere
deceptive appearance,
only apparently so, but not really so.
To use the analogy cited by Cicero,
if physical beauty is the
outward appearance of health,
the fact that it may be
imitated by cosmetics
is not, it doesn't show
that it must always be a mere semblance.
And similarly, the constancy
and order of conduct
is a manifestation of inner beauty.
One cannot exclude the possibility
that it is mere appearance.
Of course, you can pretend to be
an honorable person and you're not,
but it will still be what
makes the inner beauty
or moral beauty recognizable by others.
So I think what Panaetius has in mind
is the, as it were,
the outer appearance of inner beauty,
and the appearance need not be
a misleading appearance.
So this is the point
that Hippias didn't get.
So this then must be general decorum,
and we are still sort of some steps away
from finding a special virtue.
But at this point,
Cicero actually comes to recognize
or to admit that there are two ways
of speak speaking of decorum.
So now you turn to the next,
to the second page of the handout.
So having explained that the decorum
is the outer appearance of inner beauty,
Cicero admits that this has two senses
or two descriptions, as he says in Latin.
We understand a fittingness
of a general kind
involved with honorable
behavior as a whole.
Secondly, however, something
subordinate to this,
which relates to particular parts
of what is honorable.
The first tends to be
defined something like this.
Fitting, prepon, is what agrees
with human excellence or human virtue
in the respect in which human nature
is different from that of other beings.
So, virtue is the perfection
of a rational animal.
That part, the part that is
subordinate to the genus,
they define so as to say that
fitting is what agrees
with nature in such a way
that it shows moderation and temperance,
that's the usual virtue you
expected in their place,
with the kind of appearance
that belongs to a brave, to a free man.
Actually, Atkins' translation
has, "with the appearance of a gentleman,"
but it's not quite that, I mean.
So, well, we're still
not that much smarter.
Why would you
make this awkward move
of using, you know,
fittingness or prepon or decorum
in two different senses,
one for virtue in general
and one for a special virtue?
It seems to me that what comes out,
the motivation,
which must have been Panaetius' motivation
because Cicero wouldn't have
come up with this story,
comes out in a later quotation,
which I've also put on the handout.
Namely, this is De Officiis, 98 to 99,
"For just as the eye is aroused
"by the beauty of the
body and is delighted
"just because all the parts
"are in graceful harmony,
"so this fittingness,
shining out in one's life,
"arouses the approval of one's selves,
"because the order and constancy
"of every word and action.
"Thus, we must exercise
a kind of reverence
"towards other people or men,
"both towards the best of them,"
that's the aristocrats,
"and also towards the rest.
"To neglect what others think of oneself
"is a mark not only of arrogance,
"but also of utter laxity.
"There is a difference, however,
"between justice, with respect to others,
"and respect in considering persons.
"The part of justice is not to harm a man.
"That's what justice
prevents you from doing.
"That of respect, not to offend him."
That's, I think, the motivation.
What Panaetius is including here
and what is indeed an important step
is the desire to be liked by others,
which can also be ascribed
to the perception of beauty in a person,
because beauty is an attractive quality.
So beauty is something that we appreciate,
you know, insofar as it's beautiful,
but it also pleases us.
And so the beautiful,
as it were, behavior,
or the beautiful actions
of a virtuous person
will also, if that person
is polite and tactful
and moderate and so on and so forth,
will also make her liked by other people.
That's indeed the virtue.
It is something that the Greeks
would call (speaking in foreign language).
And it's funny that in his
sort of general exposition
of Stoic ethics in the book,
On the Ends, De Finibus,
Cicero actually mentions,
without naming Panaetius,
that the older Stoics thought that,
you know, good reputation
was something indifferent,
you wouldn't have to care about.
But some Stoics actually said
that (speaking in foreign
language) was important, too.
And I bet you that that was Panaetius.
So Panaetius thinks,
and I think, you know, the
argument is not a bad one,
that people do want to be liked by others,
and in order to be liked by others,
they have to behave in
certain kinds of way,
which can also be described as moderation
and harmonious behavior, temperance,
because you know, you
shouldn't go to excess,
you shouldn't be rude,
and so on and so forth.
So that's the second function
of this word, decorum,
and that's the one, of course,
in which it has landed
in the English language.
Decorum is, of course,
sometimes etiquette.
Decorum is the right way
of behaving and so on.
It is not used in English
any way, anywhere,
as a synonym of virtue,
but it is exactly what
gets described here.
And again, I think I have
every reason to suspect
that it got into the language from Cicero.
Everybody was reading Cicero,
so they learned that decorum
is important from Cicero.
This, of course, also
explains to a large extent
why the book was used as a sort of manual
for aspiring gentlemen
who wanted to go into politics,
you know, future leaders.
They had to know how to behave themselves.
And actually, this chapter is much longer.
The chapter on this virtue is longer
than the others in Cicero's exposition.
That is something which may
or may not be Cicero himself,
because he actually
obviously describes how a young man
in the position of his son,
an aspiring Roman aristocrat
or a senator, a politician,
ought to behave.
It is also, of course, too,
from our point of view, in any case,
an extension of the field
of morality, I think,
because those offenses,
not to offend people,
cannot always be seen as
a moral effect or air.
Sometimes it is, I think.
But those things like politeness
and a good or bad taste, and so on,
cannot, of course, be sort
of legally prescribed,
because you can't prescribe
and you can't prohibit it.
But they are, of course,
a very important way of
keeping society together.
If we were all rude to one another,
and you know, unconcerned about them,
if we didn't have the tendency
to want to be liked,
it might be much more difficult
to live with others,
and so there is a point in including this,
including tactfulness and a sense of humor
and politeness in a book
about how to behave correctly,
even though there is no moral penalty,
as it were, attached to it.
And historically speaking,
this is also a move that Panaetius made
because the Stoics were, at that time,
already sort of divided
between cynicizing Stoics
who said, you know, "Who
cares about reputation?
"I'm Diogenes, I'm living in a barrel,
"and I won't say hello to the
emperor when he comes by,"
and all kinds of other things.
And Panaetius was definitely against.
After all, he was, you know,
an aristocrat from Rhodes.
So he's on the well-mannered
side of Stoicism.
On the other hand, you
know, he has a point.
He doesn't just say, you know,
what we don't wanna be,
running around without shoes,
and you know,
and so on,
eating with our hands.
All this shouldn't be done.
But I don't think that
that's really important.
I think it is important
that he does include this kind of action
in his account of virtue,
and it is a sort of, you know,
a limiting case.
There are cases of bad taste
which are really reprehensible.
such as, you know,
wearing horrible dresses on the beach,
which are not reprehensible.
It's just sort of tasteless,
and you know, so what?
(audience member chuckling)
So, but you know,
so singing at a funeral is perhaps not,
I mean singing pop songs at a funeral
might be something that
would be reprehensible.
Cicero's examples, of course,
like most of these kinds of rules,
etiquette and so on,
they change a lot with the times.
So Cicero's examples are hilarious.
One of the obvious improprieties
is singing in the Forum.
You don't do that if you are a senator.
Hmm, why?
And then he also says you mustn't run.
If you're a senator, you walk.
You need to go slowly.
So I mean, the book is
also amusing sometimes
because it shows you something about
how they thought one ought to behave.
I guess that, you know, in 100 years,
people will say similar things about us,
so we shouldn't take
this as being a mistake.
So, well, but what I wanted to show was
that this introduction of beauty,
both as a general quality
that shows,
I mean, as a sign of inner beauty
and a sign of virtue,
and as the specific virtue of, as it were,
good taste and good manners,
makes sense and is recognized
as being a double function.
Whether the one comes before
the other, I can't tell.
But the first seems to me
to have mainly an
epistemological function.
How do we come to think
a virtue is worth having?
Why do we want virtue?
Well, you know,
we don't have to understand anything
of the underlying Stoic theory,
which is much too hard,
or at least, Panaetius may have thought,
for newcomers to philosophy.
But we can recognize
virtue as something good
when we admire under other people
because of their beautiful behavior.
And this is exactly
what Seneca puts forward
when he talks about how we acquire
what he says is our first,
it's important, I think,
to emphasize the first here,
our first notion of what is good.
We derive that notion from
observing the behavior
of people we admire,
and then that behavior is, as it were,
characterized by the kind of integrity
that makes a behavior harmonious,
because there are, as it were,
no conflicts between words and actions,
and so on and so forth.
So that's, to some extent,
an epistemological function,
but then there's also the practical side,
which is that in order
to have that virtue,
you have to behave in a way
that makes you liked by other people.
And you know, it seemed in both cases
that it made sense to appeal to beauty,
because beauty is not
only admirable, kalon,
in that sense,
but it's also pleasant.
And so in order to be, as it were,
a pleasant person to be with,
then this is how you should behave,
or so Cicero says.
I can be brief about the second book,
which is about the expedience.
Though I should emphasize, of course,
that this, namely, caring for oneself,
or what Cicero describes
as the comforts of life,
which include things
like health and wealth
and good birth and so on,
is treated separately from the virtues.
So in the second book,
he talks about how,
he mentions these things,
and then he says, "Well, but you know,"
and this must be following Panaetius
because he does refer to him,
"I'm only going to talk about the thing
"that is most important
"if you want to lead a good life.
"The most important thing
"that's expedient to you
"is having friends and supporters."
So what he talks about in that book
is how to win the hearts and minds,
as the Americans say,
of your fellow citizens
in order to get them to support you.
Again, of course, this is a great chapter
for a book that is given to future leaders
as a manual of how to become
a successful gentleman.
But what is problematic
from the point of view of Stoicism
is indeed the fact that
Panaetius treats morality,
as it were,
and it's now become called,
prudential behavior,
self-serving, self-interest,
which of course is legitimate
in many cases, separately.
Because the Stoics held,
at least the orthodox Stoics,
tended hold the view
that the good or the useful
cannot be separated from the virtuous.
So whatever is honorable
has to be expedient,
and whatever is expedient
has to be virtuous.
Now, the problem with
that, it seems to me,
and here, I am inclined to think
that it wasn't just that Panaetius
was using the language of the people,
because as much as
Socrates may have sort of
railed against separating
the useful from morality,
there's an underlying error, I think.
If you strengthen it to the extent
that you say that every
appropriate action,
which is, as it were,
not unjust, not immoral,
but it's just useful,
and not therefore, morally admirable,
has to be admirable as well.
So Plutarch, for example,
tells us that people would make fun
of the Stoics who pretended that
when the wise man, the Stoic sage,
the ideal perfect person,
blows his nose,
he is performing a virtuous
act that is admirable,
because he's doing what appropriate.
So, you know,
I think I can understand
that Panaetius can get rid of this
because he doesn't need
a thesis that is so strong.
It is perfectly sufficient to say
that, as it were, morality
always comes first.
That is to say it cannot be the case
that an action that is immoral,
the contrary of morally correct,
cannot be useful.
That you can maintain,
and following Socrates,
he would have maintained.
But he doesn't have to maintain
that any action that is
permissible, as it were,
so, not immoral, but also
not morally admirable,
but useful, also has to
be morally admirable.
So it seems to me that the
Stoics were going too far,
and I'm inclined to think
that Panaetius was sort
of silently stopping this
without thereby, as it were,
abandoning his Stoic school,
because this thesis
actually was too strong,
and it led to things like, also, okay,
when the wise man eats his breakfast,
he's already engaging in
virtuous activity. (mumbles)
Well, even Chrysippus
is said to have admitted
that no, this isn't much to admire
in a man who, as it were,
temperately abstained from a woman
with one foot in the grave.
This, of course, is Plutarch's example.
So one might say, you know,
that even though it is true
that the separation,
the separate treatment of utility
and the four virtues
in two different books,
might occur and evidently did
because Cicero mentions it,
protests from other Stoics,
Panaetius probably had
a point and didn't care.
And so the distinction has survived
because it is indeed quite helpful,
and of course, there
seem to be many things
like yes, indeed, eating a healthy diet
and being cleanly and
so on and other things
that other Stoics were
not so much talking about,
future leaders will mention
are quite useful,
but there's nothing very admirable
in brushing your teeth in the morning.
So, (chuckles)
one can see that it's a good idea,
it's appropriate,
but one doesn't have to find
it admirable in addition.
So to that extent then,
it seems to me that the
separation of those two topics,
apart from being the popular move,
is probably quite correct
even within the limits of Stoicism.
And secondly, throughout the second book,
after every recommendation
about winning the hearts and minds
and so on and so forth,
and you know, don't be
oppressive and so on,
there's always, almost like a refrain,
there is always the refrain of do all this
within the limits of justice.
So in this particular book, justice,
and that is often a synonym of morality,
becomes, as it were, a restraint
on one's self-interest.
You can follow yourself,
and just provided that
it doesn't interfere
with the right of others,
provided you keep yourself
within the limits of justice.
So that's quite clearly admitted,
and so he would therefore,
one can assume that Panaetius would say,
"No immoral action can be useful,"
because he has, you know,
included, and also,
when Cicero sort of mentions the topics,
first, you deliberate
about whether something
is morally good or morally
bad or permissible,
and then you deliberate about
whether it's useful or not.
So by the time you come,
as it were, to the second consideration,
things that might be useful but immoral
have already, as it were, been eliminated,
because they just can't be
done when they're immoral.
So far then, it seems to me
that we have reason to think
that Panaetius was not
an orthodox as a Stoic,
although he introduced some novelties.
But of course, we also
have to remind ourselves
that this isn't all
there is to Stoic ethics.
On the cognitive side,
Seneca explicitly introduces his letter
about how we come by our
first notion of the good
by insisting that it's a first notion.
So outer beauty, as it were,
serves to introduce people to beauty.
What it doesn't is explain
what inner beauty is.
So in order to understand
the Stoic doctrine,
as it were, in depth,
one would have to go beyond this,
and I think this comes out,
this is, I think, the
intention of this book.
It is not meant to be,
and the title shows that
it's not meant to be,
a complete account of Stoic ethics,
but I think it becomes
clear in a late passage,
which is rarely quoted,
and that's then at the end
of page two on your handout.
Cicero has a passage which I believe
must be taken from Panaetius.
It is in the introduction
to the third book,
which Cicero wrote on his own,
because Panaetius never did write it.
But no matter where it belongs,
it would've, I think,
it could very well have come
from Panaetius' introduction.
So what Cicero says is this,
and I'm just reading it out now.
"The duties that I discuss in these books
"are then those that
the Stoics call middle.
"And by middle, they
mean that they're shared
"and widely accessible.
"Many achieve them by the goodness
"of their intellectual talent
"and by their progress in learning.
"The duty that the same men call right
"or the appropriate action
that they call right,"
the Greek is (speaking
in foreign language),
"is complete and absolute,
"and as they say,
"fulfills all the numbers,
"and it cannot belong to
anyone except the wise man."
Now, the wise man suddenly shows up.
He's the perfect person.
And real virtue, it also turns out,
belongs only to the wise man.
So we're looking at the usual,
slightly paradoxical,
and slightly provocative
formulation of Stoic ethics.
"However," then he goes on,
"when some action is performed
"where middle duties are in evidence,
"it is seen as being abundantly perfect.
"That is because ordinary people
"cannot really understand
"how it falls short of being perfect,
"insofar as they do understand it,
"they think that nothing
has been overlooked.
"The same thing tends to
happen with poems, pictures,"
so we're back in aesthetics,
"and many other things,
"by which inexperienced
people are delighted,
"praising them when they
should not be praised.
"The reason, I believe,
"is that there some worth in them
"that attracts the ignorant,
"but they're unable to judge
"what faults each may have.
"Therefore," and now, I think
that's an important point
about what the book's trying to do,
"when they are taught
by experienced people,
"they readily abandon their view."
So he compares his treatment
of the Stoic kathekonta,
appropriate action,
as opposed to right and
morally praiseworthy action,
with showing, introducing people
to the study of art,
teaching them to appreciate pictures.
Bu then, of course, when
they are inexperienced,
they will perhaps think
that there's no difference
between say, a very good color print
and the original of a painting,
or they will like pictures,
the sort of supercilious art
critics would say are not the best
that this painter has
produced, or whatever,
or they'll see, oh, the
color isn't quite right.
So, you know,
innocent and novices
will go into the gallery
or in the museum
and find everything equally
beautiful, and so on.
And then, you know,
if, however, they then take a course
in art history and aesthetics,
they may learn to see
that actually, some of these pictures
are better than others,
and some have absolute flaws
that they didn't see in the first place.
Seneca has a different way
of explaining what happens.
He also realizes that beauty
isn't all there is to it.
So then he says,
and this is also on the handout, (mumbles)
"But by nature tend to
exaggerate what we like."
So he first explains the analogy
in outer beauty and inner beauty.
"And then underneath, however,
"there were many faults hidden
"by the appearance and the brilliancy
"of certain conspicuous acts.
"To these, we shut our eyes.
"Nature bid us amplify
praiseworthy things.
"Everyone exalts renown beyond the truth,
"and from such deeds,
"we deduce the conception
of a grand good."
So the problem with which Seneca
sort of makes obvious here
is that you can say that
people are introduced
to virtue by observing beauty,
but the Stoics also say
that there are no perfect people.
There are no Stoic sages.
Maybe Socrates was one they
sometimes grudgingly admit,
but they would certainly
never have claimed to be one.
It's an ideal.
You know, it's the perfect human being,
and although we should all, as it were,
see the ideal as something to strive for,
it is perfectly clear
that we won't get there.
So how do we actually
arrive of our notion,
given that there are no
actual examples of perfection
that we can look at
and see their inner beauty, as it were,
reflected in their actions?
Well, it is because we act
like the novices in art,
you know, we don't see the flaws,
and we form an idea,
either, sort of
as Seneca says,
by exalting,
seeing something as
perfect that isn't perfect,
or as Panaetius puts it,
by admiring something which,
if we took some philosophy courses,
we might come to see as
not being quite worthwhile.
So I think what he is saying
is this is an introduction
to Stoic philosophy.
What you are being told
is, I think, quite Stoic,
but it doesn't, as it were,
lead all the way to the end.
So that's why at the end of this,
I put the passage from Seneca in which,
since the letters to Lucilius
are a course in philosophy
that leads you to recognize
the real Stoic good.
"Therefore nature, as
we should mention here,
"tree, animal, and god,
"the last two having reasoning power
"are of the same nature,
"distinct only by virtue of
the immortality of the one
"and the mortality of the other.
"Of one of these, namely god,
"it is nature that perfects the good.
"Of the other, pains and study."
So we have to acquire perfection
through our own efforts.
Gods are perfect by themselves.
"All other things are perfect
"only their particular nature,
"not truly perfect since they lack reason.
"Indeed, to sum up, that alone is perfect,
"which is perfect according
to nature as a whole.
"And nature, as a whole,
is possessed by reason."
That is to say you have to take
a philosophy course with a Stoic
that leads you to the argument from design
to the recognition that the universe
is ruled by a divine reason,
and that's the best order in the world,
and that you then have the
desire to conform to it
because you, yourself, are rational,
and you want to do what
God wants you to do.
And then, as it were,
you figure out that
what God wants you to do
is follow the instinct He has given out.
This is how one arrives
within the framework
of general Stoicism,
at the theory of appropriate action.
We are doing things that are appropriate
that our nature makes us inclined to do
because we realize that
the divine reason has
given us these tendencies
in order to lead us to
virtue and a good life.
So this is missing from Panaetius' book,
and that's why I think
it actually is intended,
as it were, A, as an exposition
which will be read by educated people
who are not specialists in philosophy
and who don't like the Stoic terminology,
this includes many people,
but B, it is also meant as an introduction
in the sense that yes,
if you are really interested,
you have to go on further,
'til you come to the point
where you see that it's all
the divine order and so on,
and that the reason why
acting in this way is appropriate
is because nature wants you to do so.
So let me just come to a quick
conclusion about the book.
I've talked about Panaetius all the time
and why it makes sense
to introduce such a thing as the decorum.
It's both, as it were,
epistemologically important,
and it is also something
that he can describe as
what makes us be liked by others,
so by introducing the
large fields of etiquette,
politeness, and so on,
which, as I said,
made it such a good manual for young men.
But now imagine an 18th century reader.
Now these 18th century readers, of course,
weren't Stoics, right?
But they all read Cicero's
De Officiis in school
or, at the latest, in college.
And they might very well, I think,
have gotten the idea
that that was all there was to it,
because, and that, I think,
is one part of the
importance of Panaetius.
They didn't hold, of course,
the most famous Stoic thesis,
that virtue is the only good.
There are lots of English authors
who made fun of the
Stoics for that reason.
Nor did they expect a moral theory
to have the form of an ancient theory,
at least since Aristotle was starting
from a determination of the highest good,
and then teaching us how to achieve that,
the best life.
So these, we just might
not miss an account
of happiness, of the highest good,
or expect it in a book of
practical moral advice.
The famous claim that
virtue is the only good,
and therefore, also
enough to make us happy,
plays no role in the De Officiis.
And I think it is significant
that Cicero defends Panaetius of autocracy
as a Stoic against other Stoics
who maintain that conflicts
between virtue and utility
could not arise,
by arguing repeatedly,
asserting that Panaetius did have
all those fundamental pieces
and that the conflicts
were merely apparent.
But later readers of the De Officiis
could well come away with the, after all,
perfectly plausible view,
that self love and benevolence
are equally natural for humans,
and that the comforts of life
described in the second book,
including the support of friends
and other followers,
such as health, wealth, and beauty,
and of course, friends,
would be quite relevant
to human happiness.
Of course, the real
Stoics wanted to maintain
that these things were totally indifferent
in the sense that they
didn't affect our happiness
because the only thing
that counted was virtue.
What Panaetius treated in this book was,
as the title indicates,
only a part of Stoic ethics,
intended as an introduction
for educated gentlemen,
that might perhaps inspire some of them
to go on to study with the expert.
But in order to argue
for the Stoic conception
of the highest good,
seeing rational humans
as members of a community
that also included the gods,
as in the passage I
just quoted from Seneca,
a lot more would have been needed,
including the distinctions
between real goods
and evils and the so called preferred
and dispreferred indifferents,
and so on and so forth.
So,
this has actually gone away.
And as far as I can see,
I'm now skipping a discussion of people's,
I mean, there are, of course,
different interpretations of this move.
The conviction that agreement
with universal nature
is the only real good
can only be motivated by a Stoic theology.
So you have to delve into metaphysics
to arrive at the view that Cicero just,
that Seneca describes
because he has arrived, as it were,
at the end of a philosophy course,
and Panaetius is just
recommending going to one.
So a gentleman of the 18th century
would think that he
finds everything you need
in the theory that he's
offered in De Officiis.
People are attracted to virtue
because they have a moral sense,
and moral sense, of course,
was the expression of the time.
And I'm pretty inclined to believe
that it sort of naturally
came form Cicero.
And so, what more do we need?
You could recognize virtue.
You have a moral sense.
You approve of virtue because
you have the moral sense.
You disapprove of what
is unjust and unfair
and so on of life,
and then you act in accordance
with your human nature,
which, luckily, will lead
you to act virtuously
and to become a good person.
And then if you follow Panaetius' advice
about being like perilous,
you will also behave yourself
tactfully if you can,
and so on, you will be like (mumbles).
So it seems to me that it is quite likely
that readers of the 18th century
didn't think that anything was missing.
They probably, and surprisingly
overlooked the fact
that this wasn't a general
exposition of ethics.
They took it as a full account of ethics
because ethics at the time
really was about how to act,
how to decide, and so on and so forth.
And so, as it were, paradoxically,
although it was probably
not intended by Panaetius,
his book, which put metaphysics
so very much in the background,
actually led to what later ages saw
as a complete account of ethics,
namely a kind of moral sense ethics.
Thank you, and for your patience.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] I have a question.
I don't think it's directly related
to the final result, but
has to do with, I guess,
in the first paragraph.
I noticed the word,
they're careful also not to do,
to do nothing in an
unfitting or effeminate way.
- Yeah.
- [Man] And I've always been puzzled.
I noticed that recently
in a class I was taking
that Machiavelli referred to a prince
not being acting in an effeminate way,
and I'm puzzled by that,
'cause I don't quite know what that means.
Sometimes, I'm trying to understand,
since effeminate sorta suggests feminine--
- Yes.
- [Man] I'm trying to understand how
women might be situated
in this ethical view.
- Well, unfortunately, they're not.
(audience chuckling quietly)
You're quite right.
Effeminate does mean behave like a woman.
And you know, for a real man,
that wasn't how one behaved.
And thank you for mentioning Machiavelli.
Machiavelli, much maligned, I think,
was actually one of the people
who studied the De Officiis,
and his Prince is actually,
obviously meant to be something
like the kind of manual
that Cicero had provided.
And Machiavelli himself, I think,
was not a Machiavellian
in the modern sense.
So, (chuckles)
so it's not implausible
that he took this. (mumbles)
But effeminate does mean
behave like a woman,
and that's supposed to
be reprehensible in men.
The whole thing is for men.
But there is a little bit,
a little piece about women,
which says that they have to be pretty
and gentle and not talk too much.
(audience laughing)
There's not much you can do about that.
Yeah well, you know,
remember the old adage?
(speaking in foreign language)
Goes back to the early Christian church.
You know, women should shut up in church.
So. (chuckles)
Well, I mean, in this respect,
you know, it's hopeless.
It is hopeless.
It took us a long time.
Some Stoics, and ah,
well, come to think of it,
even Epicurus did admit women.
And they also, they must have realized
that women were just as smart.
But then you see that
from the Greek plays,
and you know, look at the
really impressive women
who show up there.
You don't even have to
read the philosophers.
But you know,
well, and then, I think,
I mean of course, you know,
living in this age, you
have thought about it.
One thing I have thought
about is, (mumbles)
these people were always pregnant
unless you were a nun or a Vestal Virgin
or something or other,
or you were ugly enough
that nobody would marry you.
Once these people married,
and they usually married at the age of,
fairly old age,
something like 16 to 18, you know,
they would always be pregnant,
and you know, or some of them,
I think this became worse
over time with urbanization.
But in any case, many of
them died in childbirth.
So one reason, I'm afraid, you know,
this is no reason to think
they're dumb or anything,
but one reason why women couldn't,
in fact, were physically prevented from
doing some of the things
that men could do was
that they were held back
by the fact that they were
having children all the time.
So it's perhaps not so surprising
that this century has seen more
of a liberation of women than others,
because we also have to
think of the physical side.
Thinking back, you had to be either a nun
or the most preferable
thing in the 19th century
is being the widow of a very rich man,
(audience laughing)
because once you had been married,
you could do what you liked.
But before you were married,
you were being sort of
looked after by your family,
and it was a miserable existence.
So I think, I'm afraid we
can't do much about this.
That's the time, and all we can say
is we shouldn't be too arrogant
claiming that he shouldn't have done this.
- [Woman] I wish to ask you
about the relation you see
between the innovation you say Panaetius
brought in concerning inner beauty,
and reflections on beauty
such as we can find in
Posidonius and Chrysippus,
as reported by Galen.
So the debate about when and how
we develop a sense of beauty.
So what is it, I'm trying
to pin down the novelty.
So if we compare it to Chrysippus saying
we have a sense of
beauty since we are born,
the novelty of Panaetius
is in transferring the sense of beauty
to a sense of inner beauty?
I couldn't--
- I think it's the use he makes of it.
I mean, of course, they will say
that virtue is visible
or something or other,
but to really explain it
in terms of this analogy,
as Seneca called it,
and to make it part of the way
that leads us to virtue
without having to study, as it were,
all of Stoic metaphysics,
I think that's the innovation.
I mean, that's why it shows up
at a place where one
doesn't expect it, I think.
The earliest Stoics and
your Epictetus, of course,
tended to be a lot more open
and perhaps more naive
in thinking that you could just appeal
to God and reason,
you could just appeal to
the beauty of the world
and people would follow you.
The Romans, I think,
might not have been so willing to do that.
So while you find Epictetus saying,
you know, God has wanted us,
and I mean, he doesn't argue for it.
I think the other Stoics
do argue for this.
You do find a very long
version of the argument
from design in Cicero's De Natura Deorum,
and that's definitely Stoic.
So I mean, this is something,
and that's, I think,
why it's an innovation.
To use the sense of beauty
as our way towards recognizing virtue,
and to, as Seneca puts it,
to acquire our first notion of the good.
That is to say we can
recognize things that are good,
but we can't explain, as it were,
what makes them so good.
So we can only understand
what this inner beauty comes to
once we understand what kinds of beliefs
about the, you know,
the divine order of the world,
leads to the kind of inner harmony
that they're talking about.
But it can be recognized
because it shows up in this kind of form.
I think that's the
innovation if I'm right.
I may be wrong, I mean, you know.
- [Woman] Thanks.
- [Woman] So why is that
not in The Symposium?
- Pardon?
- [Woman] The Symposium.
I'm thinking about where the antecedent,
I mean the Stoics are
readers of Plato after all.
Might one not think that
you get exactly that move
in The Symposium,
where you move from
thinking about, I mean,
move from thinking about outer beauty
to thinking about inner beauty?
- Well, Plato's beauty,
I believe ends up being pretty abstract.
- [Woman] I see.
- And here, you get from
looking at beautiful people
and looking at beautiful pictures
and looking at beautiful horses
and maybe beautiful houses,
to the idea,
and of course, in this case,
since we are going from
sort of eyes to the mind,
you look at beautiful
young men, preferably,
and then lo and behold,
you get the idea that you know,
that's not Plato.
I mean, the Stoics are very
strongly influenced by Plato.
Yeah, I mean, of course you get that
in The Phaedrus, right?
But again, you have this,
this step further,
which I think is, you know,
here, have a theory which
doesn't require that.
That's what I would say.
I mean, I'm not denying
that they were strongly influenced.
I mean, I'm the first
person to admit that.
But it's not that direct.
- [John] 'Kay well,
impossible to hear that talk
without admiring the beauty and harmony
of the composition, so thank you.
- (laughs) Come on.
(audience chuckling)
(audience applauding)
(Gisela speaking quietly)
(John laughing)
(upbeat music)